wenn wir über die helden in dieser krise
sprechen das redet man über pfleger
ärzte aber eben auch
supermarktangestellte finden sie es
gerechtfertigt wenn man über eine art
corona bonus nachdenken würde auch aus
der staatskasse also dass man diese
menschen besser bezahlt in dieser
situation
ich finde auf alle fälle richtig dass
die arbeitgeber darüber nachdenken dass
sie das in diesem zusammenhang tun und
wir geben ja jetzt sehr viel geld an die
unternehmen damit sie ihre beschäftigten
bei dieser situation unterstützen können
und manche haben jetzt natürlich auch
ganz besonders viele aufträge
abzuwickeln vielleicht ist das auch die
basis dafür dass man das machen kann
ich erwarte gerade mit meinen beamten ob
er damit es schnell geht unter
gesetzlich zum beispiel steuerfreie
zulagen gewissermaßen möglich machen
können bis zu einer gewissen
größenordnung die dann eben auch in
diesem fall helfen also steuerfreie
zulagen für pfleger für superman das
nicht rechtlich begrenzen wir müssen
darauf den rahmen zur verfügung stellen
dass man da kleine beträge zusätzlich
möglich machen kann
das erörtern wir gerade weil wir ja
immer gucken müssen wie geht es ganz
schnell und unser gegenwärtiger stand
ist bis zu einem bestimmten rahmen
können wir das wohl machen mit einer
regelung die die finanzämter treffen